[Musique]
bonsoir mardi 8 décembre bienvenue dans
le journal de tv 78 c'est l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale
en quelques minutes voici les titres de
cette édition sécheresse pic de canicule
et de pollution les effets du
réchauffement climatique se sont
observés aussi localement ces derniers
mois et 2020 pourrait bien devenir
d'ailleurs l'année la plus chaude jamais
enregistrée en cette journée mondiale du
climat
nous recevons alain bazot climatologue
au laboratoire als c'est eux c'est un
dispositif qui a du sens en cette
période épidémique un bouton pour
demander l'arrêt du bus sans contact
fonctionnant en hologramme son nom au le
stop il est testé en ce moment sur le
réseau de saint quentin en yvelines
enfin à l'heure où les théâtres sont
encore fermés une création artistique
est en cours de préparation dans
l'agglomération et j'habite hashtag
saint-quentin-en-yvelines permettra de
découvrir le territoire saint quentinois
et pour ce faire des habitants ont
enfilé le costume de comédien
[Musique]
c'est donc ce mardi 8 décembre la
journée mondiale du climat cette
occasion le premier bilan dans un
instant de l' usine de biométhanisation
mise en service voici trois ans à thoiry
je reçois d'abord alain bazot bonsoir
bonsoir qui est avec nous en
visioconférence vous êtes climatologues
chercheur au laboratoire des sciences du
climat et de l'environnement c'est une
unité mixte qui est de recherche
inquiets entre le cea le commissariat
énergie aides à l'énergie atomique le
cnrs et l'université versailles saint
quentin
alain bazot 2020 sera sur le podium des
années les plus chaudes jamais
enregistrées selon l'organisation a
météo mondiale
est-ce que 2020 d'après vous peut être
l'année la plus chaude jamais
enregistrée on sait que 2016 fait office
de record en terme de l'année la plus
chaude ce qui est sûr c'est que ce sera
vraiment une des années les plus chaudes
il faut vraiment attendre la fin de
l'année le bilan global quand savoir si
ça dépassera 2016 ou pas mais en tout
cas ce sera vraisemblablement sur le
podium donc avec 2019 aussi donc vous
voyez que c'est les années très récente
et peut-être ces années qu'ils
monopolisent les premières places des
années les plus chaudes à l'échelle you
bad de la planète
ce qui est paradoxal c'est que ça arrive
on va le savoir si c'est l'année la plus
chaude 2020 mais dans une année marquée
aussi par la crise sanitaire ce qui a
fait qu'on a beaucoup moins parlé de
l'urgence climatique est ce que sap a
été mis trop de côté en cette année on a
parlé davantage de kobe 19 peut-être pas
assez d'urgence climatique
je ne sais pas c'était normal de parler
du coc victis neuf c'est évident ça on
parle quand même ces jours ci vous savez
il ya eu la convention citoyenne qui
avait
émis des propositions pour réduire d'ici
2030 de 40% de nos émissions des
propositions sur le transport sur
l'aménagement sur l'industrie sur la
communication est actuellement tout ça
c'est en vue de la future loi climat et
tout ça c'est en débat finalement entre
les personnes de la convention citoyenne
et après le législateur c'est à dire le
parlement donc on en parle si vous
regardez ces derniers jours on en parle
c'est normal que ça ressorte beaucoup
moins évidemment que la pandémie ont
raconté qu'un travail qui est mené tout
de même
justement cette année est ponctuée par
de confinement alors l'un était total on
a vu qu'il y avait une baisse drastique
de l'activité humaine
il y avait on voyait pas grand monde
dans les rues plus de monde peut-être à
domicile ce qui a peut-être augmenter là
à la consommation l'autre confinement
plus léger avec des personnes certes en
télétravail mais on voyait moins voilà
les effets de ce confinement est ce que
vous avez observé des conséquences
directes de ces deux confinement sur sur
le climat ou peut-être c'est trop tôt
encore pour le direct sur le climat
c'est trop tôt pour le dire
il y aura pas de conséquences énormes
sur 2020 justement à cause de l'inertie
par contre on a noté une baisse des
émissions de co2 de gaz carbonique qui
n'est pas si énorme que ça c'est que 6 %
à l'échelle de la planète est de l'ordre
de 10 % pour la france est allée sur 12
mois
donc effectivement les mois de
confinement sadc davantage mais donc il
ya quand même eu un effet voilà pour
cette année sur les émissions mais sur
le climat compte tenu de l'inertie du
système n'aura pas grand chose je pense
est donc dans ce contexte où le
réchauffement climatique progresse on
pense forcément si on doit dresser les
les causes principales l'émission des
gaz à effet de serre il y en a d'autres
des causes à ce réchauffement climatique
qui qui se poursuit honnêtement la
principale cause
c'est nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et dans ses émissions de gaz à
effet de serre c'est le gaz carbonique
qui est responsable de la majorité si
vous voulez du réchauffement
un des deux tiers du réchauffement sont
attribuables au gaz carbonique que nous
émettons il faut savoir qu'on aimait
quand même plus à l'échelle globale
allégée la planète plus de 40 milliards
de tonnes de co2 a donc de ronsard était
de l'ordre de 43 s'il n'y avait pas eu
les confinements et tout ça si vous
baisser de 6% vont retomber vers 40
vous voyez bien que ça reste un chiffre
quand même énorme ouais pour les causes
et les conséquences alors on les voit
aussi à notre échelle locale dans les
yvelines
on a consacré des reportages cette année
à la sécheresse alors qu'ils impactent
directement les agriculteurs mais aussi
les forêts on a fait un reportage
notamment avec l'office national des
forêts où on a pu constater que la
sécheresse
allez aborder des répercussions très
néfaste sur sur les arbres on constate
aussi chaque année
chaque année il ya des pics de canicule
désormais plus globalement les
conséquences ce qui a des conséquences
plus désastreuses quelles peuvent être
ses conséquences plus désastreuses à
l'échelle de la planète
c'est déjà pas mal à des épisodes de
canicules et de sécheresses parce que
quand il fait chaud ça arrive à port
davantage ça peut favoriser les
incendies 1
donc en particulier cette année il ya eu
des incendies vraiment très important
californie
l'an dernier c'était en australie oui
donc l'élévation température et le fait
qu' il ya plus d'évaporation
ça fait aussi et en moins de
le débit notamment en fin d'été alors il
ya des tas d'autres conséquences comme
la fonte des glaces si vous aussi vous
allez voir la mer de glace mont blanc où
on verrait à l'élévation du niveau de la
mer l'augmentation de l'intensité des
tempêtes en particulier vers les
caraïbes donc et je ne parle pas des
impacts sur la biodiversité
parce que quand vous changez
l'environnement comme c'est le cas
rapidement vous changez les
précipitations l'humidité donc vous
changez la végétation qui a des impacts
importants sur la biodiversité en plus
de l'action humaine construction etc
on est à la fin de cette année 2020
quasiment cinq ans après l'accord de
paris qui a été pris lors de la cop 21
en 2015 qui avait suscité il faut le
dire beaucoup d'enthousiasmé à l'époque
avec 200 pays qui s'engageait à réduire
leurs émissions de gaz à effet de serre
pour limiter le réchauffement climatique
à un an et demi voire deux degrés
force est de constater que ça va être
difficile on sait que le réchauffement
atteint déjà environ 1,2 degré est ce
que les objectifs sont sont
inatteignables cc 2 degrés que l'on
avait fixé comme objectif il ya cinq ans
1.5 ce honnêtement 1.5 par rapport aux
prix industriels serait difficile de et
quelque 6 ont réussi la transition
si au court disons de des années à venir
mais de manière persistante ont réduit
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre je
dis pas qu'on sera pile à deux degrés
mais ce sera beaucoup moins avec des
conséquences beaucoup moins grave que si
on ne fait rien quand on continue à y
aller à fond sur le pétrole le charbon
et gaz
donc il ya quand même de l'espoir parce
que il ya des actions qui se met en
place il ya aussi des politiques
essayent par exemple dans les zones
urbaines de favoriser la voiture
électrique ce qui est bien en france
puisque notre électricité est décarbonée
donc des aménagements aussi de transport
voilà donc on essaye de revenir aux
trains de fret faut pas dire qu'il se
passe rien mais l'effort doit être
amplifiée et sur plusieurs et continuer
sur les années à venir a terminé sur
cette note d'espoir en cette difficile
merci alain bazot d'avoir été avec nous
chercheur au laboratoire des sciences du
climat et de l'environnement
depuis 2010 est une usine de
méthanisation territoriale a été créé
par le parc zoologique de thoiry le but
derrière une démarche environnementale
pour diminuer sa consommation d'énergie
de nombreux déchets y sont traitées pour
être ensuite récupéré par les
agriculteurs des environs pour leurs
terres premier bilan avec bixente mais
rien senti steban l'éléphant star de
l'unité de méthanisation du zoo de
thoiry
grâce à la richesse de son fumier en
effet le zoo fourni 10 % des matières
organiques traités par toribio énergie
les 90% restants sont les déchets des
agriculteurs des habitants et des
communes des environs soirée d'énergie
c'est une unité de méthanisation
territoriale
ça veut dire que nous traitons ici les
déchets du territoire dans une proximité
d'environ 20 à 25 km autour de l' usine
est également nous restituons la matière
organique et l'énergie dans un rayon
très proche d'environ 10 km la
méthanisation
c'est le processus d'accélération de la
dégradation des déchets organiques
les déchets sont traités en cinq étapes
distinctes jusqu'à la récupération d'une
énergie appelé biogaz qui est envoyé
dans l'unité d'épuration ici on prépare
le biogaz sous forme de biométhane donc
ça veut dire qu'on sépare le dioxyde de
carbone du métal après l'avoir donc
gaz riche en méthane qui sont injectés
au réseau de gaz locale un processus
biologique doublement vertueux pour
récupérer un carbone vert mais également
une réutilisation des déchets une fois
traitées par les agriculteurs
ce procédé permet d'être de dégrader le
carbone sous forme d'énergie en 21 jours
donc c'est assez rapide
ensuite bien entendu pour la matière
organique qui doit retourner aux champs
là nous avons environ six mois de
stockage donc qui nous permet aussi de
parfaire cette matière qui retourne au
chant un processus locale qui aspirent à
s'étendre dans tout le territoire pour
réduire les trajets de transport des
matières organiques
chacun pourrait ainsi agir contre le
réchauffement climatique en faisant
traiter ses déchets dans l' usine de
méthanisation la plus proche
environnement toujours mais à villepreux
un nouveau lieu de promenade a été
aménagé en entrée de ville à la place de
l'ancienne friche près du nouveau
quartier du haut des moulins est la
pépinière de 8 hectares comprendra
plusieurs chemins et des espaces
d'observation miquel et demi d'euros une
bouffée d'air aux portes de villepreux
après un an de travaux une nouvelle
pépinière de 8 ha vient d'être aménagée
près du nouveau quartier des eaux du
moulin de la ville un projet attendu par
les 10000 habitants de la commune
il faut voir d'où l'on part c'est à dire
que cette cet espace là n'était pas
valorisées c'était une friche où on
retrouvait d'ailleurs des carcasses de
voitures brûlées 1 c'était c'était ce
genre de choses qu'on retrouvait dans
cet endroit là et qui posait aussi son
lot de problèmes de sécurité
donc justement l'ambition de remettre un
espace vert de remettre de la
biodiversité en ville en aménageant en
aménageant cet espace c'est évidemment
quelque chose qui qui est très positif
pour la commune de villepreux
dans cet espace on retrouve des chemins
pour permettre de circuler des bancs
également des pontons pour pouvoir
observer la plaine de versailles
au total la communauté d'agglomération
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines investi
près de 300000 euros
saint quentin en yvelines c'est 60% des
espaces non bâtis donc des espaces verts
agricole et forestier cet espace de 8 ha
donc s'ajoutent à ces 60% et
nous avons au niveau de l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines investi
pour pouvoir ouvrir cette pépinière qui
était tout simplement une friche
forestière la nouvelle pépinière n'est
pas encore totalement terminée des
arbres fruitiers vont être plantés dans
les prochaines semaines un parcours
pédagogique sera également mise en place
transports avec le trafic du rer c qui
reste perturbé une semaine après
rappelez-vous le coffrage de 300 tonnes
servant à la réalisation d'une poutre en
béton s'est effondrée sur les voies à
paris hier lundi les énormes travaux de
déblayage ont débuté 150 personnes
mobilisés 24 heures sur 24 pour les
effectuer
350 tonnes de matériel dont deux grues
ferroviaires ont été dépêchés sur place
pour le moment pas de date fixe estimé
pour la fin du chantier en attendant la
circulation reprend peu à peu sur la
ligne c empruntée chaque jour par 540
mille voyageurs comptait deux trains par
heure toutes contrées deux trains par
heure dans les deux sens de circulation
sur l'axé versailles saint quentin en
yvelines plusieurs gares franciliennes
restent non desservies retrouvez toutes
les informations sur le lien qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran un bouton
holographique qui permet de signifier au
chauffeur que l'on souhaite descendre
prochaine ares et le principe dolo stop
l'innovation est testé actuellement
pendant deux mois sur cinq véhicules du
réseau stibus dans l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines pas de contact
pour plus de sécurité dans le contexte
épidémique actuel
le reportage de mélanie poké
c'est un geste réalisé des dizaines de
fois par jour par les usagers mais
depuis ce lundi à saint quentin en
yvelines plus besoin de toucher le
bouton stop un hologramme le remplace je
trouve que c'est très bien je m'étais
pas rendu compte
et là je découvre un nouveau système
c'est très bien moi je trouve que c'est
c'est bien quoi enfin avec tout ce qui
se passe en ce moment avec le co vie 19
c'est bien dans les transports en commun
le principe de l'auto stop c'est une
écran lcd qui est réfléchie par des
miroirs et ses miroirs enchaîne cette
image dans l'air en forme d'hologramme
on avait juste à toucher du doigt
l'image qui est dans cette ère pour
activer la demande d'arrêt qui se trouve
dans les véhicules
cinq bus de deux lignes sont pour le
moment non équipés de ce système la 401
reliant maurepas à versailles et la 415
permettant d'aller de bois d'arcy au
mesnil saint denis
elle transporte eu mille personnes
chaque jour la réflexion on l'avait on
l'avait depuis depuis benghazi un an
donc c'était c'était bien avant
heureusement effectivement avec la
colline 19 ça a précipité et on s'est
dit effectivement c'est aujourd'hui
qu'il faut qu on line up on inaugure
pour rassurer les clients vous savez les
transports publics sont sûrs aujourd'hui
lancé lundi 7 décembre l'expérimentation
va durer deux mois
à terme ratp dev espère équiper les 170
véhicules du réseau stibus et la
développer dans notre société de
transport on resta à saint quentin en
yvelines avec le lancement depuis
quelques jours de l'application mobile
shopping sky elle est désormais
disponible sur les plateformes app store
et google play l'application permet de
soutenir vos commerces de proximité en
achetant local vous y retrouver les
commerçants des douze communes de
l'agglomération pour réaliser vos
commandes en ligne possible 7 jours sur
7 et 24 heures sur 24 chaque achat vous
permet de cumuler des points de fidélité
pour le moment 58 commerçants sont
référencés pour faire partie de chopines
sky les inscriptions sont encore
possibles pour les professionnels et
n'hésitez pas à vous rapprocher des
services de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est un secteur en grande difficulté
avec la crise économique celui des
espaces de loisirs
d'or certaines structures ont perdu
jusqu'à 80 % de leur chiffre d'affaires
à maurepas l'urban jump a dû refermer
ses portes poussant les propriétaires
dans une situation très difficile les
précisions de mélanie poké le loisir
aimerait bien rebondir à l'urban je me
demande pas l'ambiance est plutôt morose
avec les deux confinement le site accuse
265 mille euros de perte de chiffre
d'affaires fermeture de trois mois nous
avons rouvert à la pire période parce
qu'ils nous avons une saisonnalité
inversée gt étant le moins propice aux
affaires
ils refermé au moment où l'activité a
été la meilleure dans les vies très très
mal parce que bon déjà nous sont déduits
et de vie à l'habitude de vivre il a
fait vraiment bon et ensuite au niveau
de l'entreprise
c'est une véritable catastrophe parce
que les aides sont certes importantes
ils sont nés très très très très loin du
compte propriétaire de deux autres
structures de loisirs à maurepas
elancourt sébastien emploie 15 salariés
tous actuellement en chômage partiel
partout on entend parler du click and
collect est une manière de se refaire un
autre niveau
c'est impossible je ne peux pas sortir
avant une bouteille du trampoline et
puis même si on avait un vendeur des
places à l'avancé
ce serait du chiffre d'affaires commente
ici près et qu'on ne ferait pas l'année
prochaine ce qu'ils utilisent
selon l'association professionnelle se
passe douze mille emplois directs sont
menacés avec une visibilité jusqu'au 31
décembre sébastien espère ne pas avoir à
définitivement baissé son rideau pour
refermer ce journal cette création
artistique pour découvrir
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise la
compagnie 7,70 prépare son spectacle son
nom j'habite hashtag saint quentin en
yvelines dans lequel les habitants ont
revêtu le costume de comédien justin
brasier nicolas landresse trappe
coignières ou encore magny les hameaux
voilà de quoi parlera le spectacle
j'habite hashtags saint quentin en
yvelines
une création de la compagnie 7 septembre
composé de témoignages d'habitants de
sky
objectif donner la parole aux saint
quentinois j'ai déposé un projet
effectivement auprès de la communauté
d'agglo de saint quentin en yvelines
pour faire parler tous les saint
quentinois et saint-quentinoise et pour
essayer un petit peu de comprendre ce
que c'est est ce ce processus de
communauté d'agglo qui a juste un nom et
qui voilà qui est divisé en douze villes
et puis aussi parce que ma compagnie
travaille beaucoup sur le témoignage un
questionnaire a été établi en hameaux
pour interpeller les habitants via les
réseaux sociaux
cinq personnes ont été choisies pour
participer à la création ils les ont à
coeur de parler de leur ville le trap
j'y suis depuis le disant tu as beaucoup
de choses qui ont été dites et rassure
trappe depuis des années des années
moi j'aimerais ak c'est justement à tous
ces stéréotypes aujourd'hui c'est plus
ce que c'était et c'est une ville où
finalement comme toutes les autres où on
se sent bien
j'ai trouvé super intéressant de pouvoir
parler de sa ville d'autant que j'y suis
moi depuis plus d'une trentaine d'années
une commune plutôt riche en événement
riche en équipements et puis surtout une
population plutôt solidaires les
témoignages écrits des habitants de sky
seront mis en scène et théâtralisée deux
comédiens sont présents sur le projet
pour accompagner le groupe dans le
processus de création qui a des petites
salles à jouer on prend les jouets et
ouais être avec les encadrer couet temps
au lieu de l'encadrement ce serait
plutôt accompagnement sur l'intérêt
d'être là en soutien d'être là pour
aider à la mise en scène si jamais il ya
besoin de conseils
le spectacle aura lieu le samedi 13
février au petit théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en partenariat
avec le musée de la ville c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi on
se retrouve dès demain mercredi pour une
nouvelle édition belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]